if you're buying a house because you
don't do it run for your life Mr Morgan
H he's the author of the psychology of
money one of the bestselling business
books of this decade he can help anyone
build wealth and change their life the
world is split between people who don't
know how to start making money and
people who don't know when to stop
making money and if you are stuck in a
low-income job you feel like you don't
have the opportunity to generate wealth
but once you realize that opportunities
are available for everybody you can
choose where you want to live what job
you want when you retire because you can
be rich prove it people like Ronald Reed
and he was a janitor what does it take
to amoun Mr Reed's $8 million Fortune
he's a fascinating story of somebody who
became Rich despite not having the
skills that you normally associated with
wealthy people then there's Warren
Buffett he's worth $100 billion but the
real secret to their success investing
my parents are a great example of this
we were very poor no Financial
background and they have like minimal
financial interest but now they'd
probably be in the top 3% of
professional investors if you want to do
well with money you don't need to be a
genius if you have endurance in your
investing you're going to be filthy rich
but when most people say I want to be a
millionaire what they actually mean is I
want to spend a million dollars I want
some nice clothes bigger house the nicer
car ask yourself what is your
relationship with money if your
expectations rise faster than your
income you're never going to be happy
with your money that's the problem so if
I have a100 what's the first thing that
I should do I keep it as painfully
simple as I can so
ladies and gentlemen you're about to
meet the man whose book changed my
entire life as it relates to money and
finance about four or five years ago my
brother who's a investment banker said
Steve there's one book I need you to
read about wealth investing and money in
finance and he passed me a book called
the psychology of money that book
changed my fortunes it is the reason
I've been a successful investor and it's
the reason I've been able to hold on to
my wealth and build it it's this man and
that's the reason why you need to stay
tuned and listen to this
[Music]
episode
Morgan you wrote what I would consider
to be the greatest book on money and
finance ever written I say that because
I remember when I came into money when I
was 25 20 no 27 27 28 years old and my
brother turned to me and said there's
one thing I ask of you he said you have
to read this book called the psychology
of money it will stop you losing all of
the money you've just earned from your
career and it changed my life I've
talked about it for years and years ever
since and that's why I was so Keen to
have this conversation with you because
I really believe if people choose to
listen to this conversation it stands
the chance of changing those two so
let's begin why of all the things that
you could do with your life Morgan why
are you writing books about the subject
matter that you explore what is the
reason well first that's a that's a big
statement that's a lot to live up to
it's kind of scary to hear that because
I've I've often been and this gets to
the why when I I've just find it as
selfish writing where I write for an
audience of one and that is me and I
like to think of myself as a pretty
selfless person but for writing I don't
try to say I'm going to write a book for
this person or that person or that
audience I write what I'm interested in
and I write it in a way that I think is
interesting and I try to solve my own
problems and then I take a leap of faith
that if this is interesting to me and
it's going to help me maybe it'll help
somebody else that's very different from
the traditional writing style of saying
know your audience know your audience
very quickly turns into Pander to your
audience and I think a lot of people
maybe they don't even know it but if
they read a book and they don't
necessarily like it it's because they
were being pandered to they were being
spoken to in a way that a person would
never speak to them in real life so I
just this is almost like my diary I
think in terms of these are the topics
that I found interesting for myself and
so I guess that's the why I feel like
I've really found myself in a career
where I can just figure out my own
problems and try to figure out what I
think and what's interesting to me and
then kind of put it out to the world and
then hope that other people will enjoy
it let's start with the psychology of
money what is the benefit to my life if
I understand the things that are written
in the psychology of money well let me
start with I think most Finance books
will their their answer to that question
would be when you're done with this book
you will know how to pick stocks better
you will know how to balance your
checking account or what credit cards
that you should use for my book I think
when you're done with it I hope that you
will just look in the mirror and say who
am I which is kind of what I did with
this trying to figure out who I am and
what I want and why I was insecure why I
wanted to show off to other people the
car that I drove so if you become more
introspective about who you are and what
you want out of life and what money can
do for you and cannot do for you and
become a little bit more introspective
about why you think
about where you are in the social
hierarchy and greed and fear and why you
think about these things that you do I I
honestly think that I I I hope at least
because it was this way for me that when
you're done for with the book that's
kind of when the learning begins because
maybe this will just spark a bit of
curiosity for you to then go for a walk
and think about what you want out of
life and whatnot so I think in most
books when you're done with the last
page the learning is done this I hope is
just sparked something in you that will
get you to think more clearly about what
you want with money and what money can
and cannot do for you part of that
journey of understanding what you want
helps you to define the word on the
front of this book wealth what is your
definition of wealth well I I I made up
these definitions in the book so these
are just my things that I made up but I
defined rich as you have enough money to
buy what you want to pay for your
mortgage to make your car payment to go
out to dinner with your friends you have
money in the bank wealth I think is very
different wealth is money that you did
not spend and maybe you will not spend
so wealth is hidden it's the money that
you didn't spend on a car it's the money
that you didn't spend on a big house you
didn't spend on jewelry and that's
really important because wealth that's
saved up the unspent money is what gives
you Independence and autonomy and just
the ability to wake up every morning and
do whatever you want with your with your
life and so I think separating that is
really important because when most
people say I want to be a millionaire
what they actually mean is I want to
spend a million dollars that's what they
mean and when I think about being a
millionaire I think it's you have a
million dollars that you're not going to
spend and that because you're not going
to spend it you have this giant cushion
that will give you Independence and
autonomy and so you can wake up tomorrow
and say I can do whatever the hell I
want today I can work for who I want I
can work for as long as I want I can
retire when I want the World is Yours
like every bit of savings that you have
is a piece of your future that you own
it's you're just buying your time in the
future so that it's yours and you can do
whatever you want with it and that to me
has always been the goal there's a quote
from Charlie Munger where he says I
never wanted to become rich I just
wanted to become independent and that
when the first time I read it it was
like that's me too that's what I want I
don't want a Lamborghini I don't want a
mansion and a yacht I want to wake up
every morning and just say whatever I
want to do today it's mine nobody's
going to tell me where to work when to
work what to do it's all me and to me
for not just work but for your family
life for your health for your mental
sanity there's nothing more important
than that it sounds like you're talking
about your
father my dad it was he has such an
interesting background my my my mother
too their background is so crazy and I
didn't realize how crazy it was until I
was an adult the early part of my
childhood when my parents were in school
we were very poor my parents were
students living off of student loans and
grants we had no money and then my dad
became a doctor when I was 12 or 13 and
things changed it wasn't we were not
rich but like things got very
comfortable and what was really
important is that the frugality that my
parents had to have when they were poor
stuck with them even after they started
making a little bit of money they didn't
buy Lamborghini no no we grew up in a
very like modest house it was a nice
house and we took some like decent
family vacations but my we always live
well below our means way below our means
did that confuse you because you must
have known that your dad had the money
yes particularly when I was probably
like 16 17 and I could learn like how
much does a doctor make you can go look
it up and figure it out and then it was
like I definitely looked down on my
parents at that age because I was like I
know you can afford a better car I know
you can buy me better Christmas presents
I know we can afford a bigger house and
you're and you're not doing it because
you're mean I think that was I think
that was my view and then it really
clicked about 10 years ago this is not
that long ago so my dad is an ER doctor
which is one of the most stressful jobs
that you can imagine it's literally
people dying in your arms every day and
he did this for 20 years and after 20
years of doing this night shifts
children dying in your arms literally
every every week he said he he had had
enough it was it was a lot he put in his
dues he did it for 20 years and he said
I'm done I'm I'm going to retire and the
reason he could do that is because he
had saved up so much money he was living
well below his means they had a very
high savings rate the moment he woke up
and said I want to be done he was done
that was it and if you can trast that
with so many other people including some
of his colleagues who were also burnt
out at age 60 who also burnt out by
having people die in their arms for 20
years they wanted to retire and they
couldn't because they had the bigger
house because they had the nicer car
that I thought that we should have had
when we were growing up and when they
quit and moved on to their next phase of
Life they got so much happier and so it
was like so that this was 10 years ago I
was in you know in my late 20s at this
point I was like now I get it he was
Frugal he saved a lot and that made him
independent and the Independence made
him happier than any car would have done
made them happier than any big house
would have done so it's like I think
that is one of the keys to happiness
happiness is like the most complicated
topic you can imagine but one of the big
puzzle pieces is independence and
there's been a lot of work on this
studies on this of like one of the
things that makes people really happy in
life is having control over what they're
doing and it's more so the flip offf
side of that it's like what makes people
very unhappy in life not having control
over what happens in their future having
control over their schedule where
they're going to work whether they're
going to get laid off having that
uncertainty is a massive anchor and wait
on your life about your health
absolutely I mean that was a big thing
for my dad to he's working night shifts
for for 20 years with this it it's very
bad for your health it's not great at
all so the ability the financial ability
to just wake up one day and say I'm done
done with that is huge I I was reading
studies about this idea of autonomy
because I was trying to figure out what
you have to have professionally to love
your work and I came up with these five
different points one of them was
autonomy and control and I I came up
with that because I read studies where
people who work jobs where they had low
autonomy and control had physiological
consequences they were more likely to
get disease they experienced stress
significantly more more likely to have
cardiovascular problems and heart
disease which is the single biggest
killer of of people generally I thought
[__] hell just not having control in
your life makes your body shut down yes
you know this is something that I think
everybody has experienced if they have
something really stressful going on at
life they get into bed they're tired you
can feel your heart pounding like the
physiological response of stress is huge
it's massive and if you have that going
on every day for 5 years 10 years 20
years 30 years forget about it forget
about it this this great quote from John
de Rockefeller he's the richest man in
the world and he lived till I think he
was 99 something like that he was 97 and
his doctor talked about why like his key
to longevity and the doctor said quote
he never lets anything bother him he
spends plenty of time outside and he
leaves the table when he's still a
little bit hungry that was his key to
longevity it was just and and when you
read his biography you realize how true
that was no matter what was going on in
his life and the most stressful business
conditions you can imagine none of it
ever bothered him he just had ice in his
veins and he could just keep going and
so I I I do think that's that's
definitely one of like the keys to
physical health is lowering that amount
of stress and there are not many other
things in life that are going to
increase the stress you have than not
having control over what you're doing in
life Freedom chapter seven of your book
this is the broadest lifestyle variable
that makes people happy doing something
you love but on a schedule you can't
control starts to feel the same as doing
something you hate psychologists call
this reactants that's right you know I I
do think there are a lot of I think the
best example are CEOs who might make $30
million a year $50 million a year but
they have no control over their time
every single second of their day is
planned and demanded by somebody else
and they have to do things that they
don't want to do if they wake up and
they're tired too bad you got to go to
your meetings today if they wake up and
they're exhausted too bad you have to
travel to China to close this deal they
have no control over their time and
compare that to someone who makes much
less but they wake up they can wake up
and do whatever they want whatever they
want to do you want to hang out with
your friends you want to sleep in you
want to take a nap at 2 o'clock whatever
you want to do the person who I think
really sticks out in that in that vein
is Warren Buffett who is the the CEO who
makes a zillion dollars a year he's
worth hundred billion dollar but if you
dig into how he structured his day total
control 100% autonomy can do whatever
the hell he wants all day long what he
wants to do is get up and go to work but
he he has delegated things so
effectively that he can do whatever he
wants and that's not only the key to his
I think business success but his health
lifestyle success and why he's 93 and
still going as strong as
ever I I was thinking about my calendar
when you were talking about the CEO that
makes $30 million a year but is just
dragged around by his schedule sounds a
lot like me to be honest I feel like the
more successful I've got in my
professional career the more my calendar
the minute I wake up in the morning I'm
just like a puppet master to these
little boxes on my Google Calendar yeah
they drag me around the world and
there's very little I actually said to
my assistant about a month ago I was
like um Sophie please can you do me a
favor could you just put lunch in for 30
minutes because I'm not eating could you
just put like could you just put that in
midday every day at the same time so you
can breathe so I can have a little bit
of a moment where I do nothing and then
also the other thing I've put in now I
have a personal trainer 7even days a
week and I've just put that in my
calendar it was before then a residual
beneficiary as was everything for me
well not for me because my work is for
me but um it it got the time that was
left over when all my priorities were
done and I do reflect on that and go
like how like a when does that stop
because it's clearly not going to stop
when I make money because I have the
money and B how much control do I
actually have and you know what I do
sometimes I think I've notic this about
myself I think sometimes I cancel things
just to prove to myself that I still
have control that's great see that's a
good thing there's a quote from nin talb
where he says like you are wealthy when
the money that you deny tastes better
than the money you accept so you get
someone comes to you with a business
deal and you say no thanks I don't want
it when that tastes better to you than
accepting the deal it feels better to
you that's like one definition of of
Rich there's another great quote from
tedward he says the world is split
evenly between people who don't know how
to start making money and people who
don't know when to stop making money and
I think there are a lot of people that
are watching this that are in kind of
our field who are easily in the ladder
they have all the money that they could
ever want to spend or maybe not not that
much but they have more money than they
ever thought they would have but for
every goal that they hit oh whenever my
net worth is X all my problems are going
to go away everything's going to feel
great and then they hit X and they just
keep moving the goalpost down and down
so I read in the book that like the
hardest Financial skill is getting the
goal post to stop moving it's the
hardest thing in the world it's hard for
everybody because virtually everybody
thinks if my net worth or my income was
this level I'll be fine I'll feel great
no more problems I'll wake up every
morning with a smile on my face and then
if you're lucky enough or you work hard
enough to get there you realize it's not
the case at all you're just going to
keep pushing it keep pushing it keep
pushing it forever have they done
studies to test that in terms of
analyzing whether people's goal posts
move off into the future even when
they're like billionaires and whatever I
mean here's here's the broadest way that
I would frame this that has been studied
if you look at America today the average
household adjusted for inflation is
making twice as much money than they
were in the 1950s to adjusted for
inflation the average household double
the income that they were back then and
we're less happy the statistics that try
to measure happiness over time it's not
an easy thing to do but we're less happy
today than we were back then and this is
why like look can money buy happiness
yes and to some extent does it yes like
people who are in abject poverty are not
as happy as people who are covering the
basic and they have food and shelter etc
etc but over time when you when the
society is getting richer and you're
comparing yourself to other people and
maybe the average American's income
doubled but so did their neighbors so
did their co-workers so did their
siblings so you just automatically
adjust to that I talked about
Rockefeller before Johny Rockefeller who
died in I think the 1930s he was worth
adjusted for inflation almost half a
trillion dollar during his day adjusted
for inflation but he never had during
his life penicillin
Advil sunscreen polio vaccine keep keep
going down the list of things that
virtually everyone can take advantage of
today that he never had but you can't
say that the average American is living
better than Rockefeller today because we
have all of these technologies that he
never did because we just look at what
other people have and assume that that
is the Baseline so you can imagine a
world in which my kids my grandkids are
earning twice as much as me adjusted for
inflation and they're no happier for it
because the new technologies whatever it
will be that would seem like magic to
you and I will just become their
Baseline and that's always been the case
if there was if Thomas Jefferson or
somebody came to the year 2023 he would
faint at the new technologies and the
medical discoveries that we have and
these are technologies that you and I
don't spend one second being grateful
for because we've just accepted them as
a new Baseline it reminds me of
something in your new book which is out
in November which is you know I've
gassed up a lot of books on this podcast
before but this is one of my favorite of
all time it's just so easy to read and
so engaging because you you're one of
those authors in this book that realizes
the world that the reader living in and
they are busy and they want the point
and they want you to you know give them
not one word more than you need to it is
so brilliant it's so brilliant um in
this book you talk about exactly that
you say the first rule of happiness is
low expectations yep and that's exactly
what you're talking about is comparison
is the thief of Joy because it just
raises our own expectations right when
with that out the window goes our
happiness yeah and it's it it it seems
counterintuitive to people that if you
want to be H for most people it's if you
want to be happier you need to be
ambitious you need more you need to make
more money work harder have a more
successful startup whatever it would be
and there's that's true but that's half
the equation the other half the equation
is keep your expectations low so the gap
between those two it's the gap between
those two that actually accru to
happiness over time how did you learn
that I think it's just I think there
have been a couple little stories that
really stuck out to me one that I love
that just knocked me on my ass the first
time I read it was stepen Hawking the
late physicist who was without
exaggeration one of the smartest people
to ever walk this planet he was just an
absolute genius and a quirky of course
is that he had a motor neuron disease
and he was paralyzed from head to toe he
had no control over his body he spoke
through a computer not a single muscle
in his body could he actually control by
himself so he was you know
physiologically it's one of the worst
lives that you can imagine and he did an
interview with the New York Times a
couple years before he died and during
the interview he's talking about how
happy he was and how amazing his life
was and the New York Times said they
asked him they said what is your secret
to happiness like if there's anyone who
has the right to complain about life
it's it's that guy and he's talking
about how happy he was and he said my
expectations were reduced to zero when I
was 21 which is when he got his disease
and he said everything else since then
has been a bonus so this is like the guy
who whose life is like has ended up in a
way that most people watching that would
say like that's among the worst
scenarios you can imagine and he's
probably happier than you and I because
his expectations were so low that just
waking up in the morning and seeing the
sunrise and getting to go to work and
talk to people was this magical gift I
mean you can imagine not to get too
morbid about this but imagine you're on
your deathbed and the doctor is very
confident that you're going to die
tomorrow and let's say that you make it
one more day what what is that Sunrise
going to feel like what's that you know
holding your your wife's hand for one
more day going to feel like it' be
amazing just because your expectations
were on the floor and so it it's always
like that and you go through life seeing
so many people who have everything all
the money the great family all the
health the beauty everything you can
imagine and they're not happy for it and
it's because with everything that they
have their expectations rise not only to
that level they might rise above it so
if you are some if your expectations
rise faster than your income you're
never going to be happy with your money
no matter how much money you make you
can make a billion dollars a year but if
you needed and wanted 1.1 billion you're
broke you feel broke and the reverse of
that is true too there are people who
make $50,000 a year but if they only
need 40 to be happy they're stoked they
feel great and so that's I think that's
one of the reasons so important is
because managing your own expectations
is more in your control than managing
your circumstances in terms of raising
your income raising your invest in
returns not it's not that you can't
control raising your income you can be
ambitious and smart and entrepreneurial
of course but it's more in your control
to inside your head to say I'm going to
try to want less that that's just a
mental exercise that's it's not to say
it's easy it's not easy at all but you
have total control over doing it so how
in a practical sense can one go about
keeping their expectations below their
circumstances I guess here's here's one
that really made an impact on me it's
great that we're in La cuz that's where
this story took place I was a valet here
in La all throughout college at a festar
hotel here in town so a I I was young I
was you know aged 19 to 24 or something
like that and all day it was people
driving in in Ferraris and Lamborghinis
and rolls-royces and one day it hit me
just I I I remember the moment because
it was like out of the blue it hit me
whenever someone would drive in in a
Rolls-Royce or something never once
would I look at the driver and say that
guy is cool like wow look at him he's so
cool what I did is I imagined myself as
the driver and then I thought if I was a
driver people would think I'm cool and
it was like wait don't you see like the
disconnect here nobody cares about the
driver but they want to be the driver
because they think people will then care
about them and once you realize that
like the takeaway is nobody is thinking
about you as much as you are nobody
cares about your stuff as much as you do
nobody cares about your car or your
house or your clothes or your jewelry as
much as you do because to the extent
that they're even looking at them
they're looking at your car looking at
your house really what they're doing is
imagining themselves with that nice car
they're not giving you the credit
they're imagining themselves having it
so once I realize like that was the game
that was being played in society once
you once you recognize that's the game
your willingness your desire to show off
plunges and of course I I like nice
stuff I like nice cars I want some nice
clothes I live in a decent house but
once you realize that it plunges and I
think the most valuable Financial skill
that anybody can have is not needing to
impress other people if you don't need
to impress other people that is an asset
on your balance sheet that is worth a
billion dollars because so much of
society as a whole and individual is
just geared towards how can I get other
people's attention how can I show off to
other people how can how can they like
me more I both agree and understand but
agreeing and understanding is different
from being able to do I think at the
society level it will never be it'll
always be like that same as ever it's
never it's never going to move away from
that if you can manage it around the
edges at the individual level it's
massive for your life one thing that's
important here is that if you are a
young person and you're kind of looking
for a spouse a mate a boyfriend a
girlfriend a wife a husband whatever it
would be then your ability to look
really nice and to signal and to kind of
put up your peacock feathers is
important and I get it and I did it back
in the day once you are more settled
down in your career in your
relationships if at that point you are
still hanging on to the desire to
impress other people that's when it's
broken that's when it's just pure net
loss in your life because you're trying
to show off for people who you don't
even need or want to love you there's a
great quote from Warren Buffett where he
says the definition of success is when
the people who you want to love you do
love you and so for me it's like five
people it's like my parents my wife and
my kids and like that's it that's it
those are the people who I want to love
me and if they love me I probably have 9
% of the happiness that I'm capable of
and if they don't love me and then I'm
never going to have more than like 10%
of the happiness that I'm capable of in
that chapter about happiness you talk
about your friend Brent as well in his
theory on marriage yeah my friend Brent
bishaw has this great theory on marriage
where he says marriage only works if
both Partners want to serve the other
partner and expect nothing in return so
you wake up every morning you say I want
to serve my spouse but I expect nothing
in return from them and if you both do
that simultaneously you're both
pleasantly surprised because what
happens is I didn't expect you to do
anything for me but you did and vice
versa and both of you just wake up every
morning you're like but you did that for
me you you helped me out here you you're
empathetic to me there and it feels
great you exceeded my expectations
exceed my expectations and I think what
breaks down any marriage or career or
whatever it would be is when you become
needy like nothing breaks love more than
being needy and really what needy is is
just your expectations are so high that
you wake up and you say expect you to do
this for me I expect you to help me I
expect you to serve me that's just like
massively high expectations that you
have in that relationship it's it's also
like expecting an external factor in
that case your partner to validate you
in some way or to and that kind of goes
back to your point about money where in
order to stop showing off and focusing
on those five people that we want to
love
ourselves we need to understand and
ideally solve our often toxic
relationship ship with like our need for
validation and that I guess brings me to
the first chapter in your book where you
talk about the stories of money that we
have and where they've come from and
something that's always baffled me is
when you go into low-income areas
there's more gambling shops yeah and I
can attest to it when I was 18 19 years
old and I'm shoplifting pizzas to feed
myself and I'm doing all sorts of stuff
when I got my student loan in I was in
university for one day and they gave me
like the first payment of my student
loan I don't think I've ever said this
before
I put the entirety of the payment on a
bet wow and I lost it in a six in the an
injury time of that football match I
don't bet and did you need that money
for tuition like it it was then it was
then gone I needed it to eat yeah I
wasn't speaking I had no money but I
don't come from I didn't come from money
my parents I'd gone to University with
50 Quid and I got this like, sent to me
from student loan whatever I was so
reckless with money when I didn't have
money the minute I got money it's like
everything just chilled the [__] out and
I I became really longterm term patient
I made really responsible decisions I
stopped buying flashy things I like
don't even own a TV now I'm very Sim I
feel like the more money I have the less
my material desires are for sure for
sure when I say that out loud I'm like
oh absolutely why is that that when we
have less we are Reckless without money
well I think there's two sides to this
one of my theories is
that what everyone wants in the world is
respect and admiration from other people
and there's kind of two ways to get that
you can get your respect and admiration
through your wisdom through your love
through your humor or if you don't have
that to offer from the to offer to the
world you're going to get it through
your material possessions so if you can
gain respect and admiration through your
business success your wisdom your love
your friendship great then you're going
to get it and you're going to fulfill
that bucket if you can't get it from
those things then you're like well might
as well show off my car it's all I got
to do that's all I have I think that's
one side of it so as you become more
successful your desire to show off
diminishes because you're gaining
respect and admiration through other
things that that are not Material the
other side of this that's so important
is that you know I saw this statistic
years ago that the poorest of 10% of
Americans buy like 80% of the lottery
tickets in America and these are people
who can like barely feed themselves low
as 10% they're literally struggling to
put a roof over the head and feed
themselves are going out hand over fist
buying scratcher tickets and the the
knee-jerk reaction when you hear that is
morons what are you doing you idiot and
maybe that is the right reaction but I
started thinking about it and it was
like okay maybe if you try to put
yourself in those people's shoes maybe
they would say something like this if
you are stuck in a low-income job and
you feel like there's no way out you
feel like you don't have the opportunity
to work your way up the ladder become an
entrepreneur you feel like you're stuck
in this position buying a lottery ticket
might be the only thing in life that
gives you a little bit of hope it might
it's might be what feels like literally
your only ticket to get out and that
might be not something that you and I
feel like because we have we we we at
least feel like we might have other
opportunities I it's you're so right
because when I gambled what I then did
the same day before the result of my bet
or my lottery ticket came in and I said
this to my team the other day is I would
go on right move and like AutoTrader and
look at stuff that I would buy if I won
yeah yeah I think there's a sense too
that if you are stuck in a lower spot in
life if you have a feeling that the
world is unfair and very often it is so
some maybe that that that might be the
right mindset but if you feel the world
is unfair then it's very natural to
think I might as well cheat too if the
world's unfair why not might as well
cheat and I think that at least at some
level has some explanation for the
relationship between poverty and crime
that word hope is it's so it's so true I
think it's true too you just a glimpse
of Hope because it gives you even if
it's a
0.00001% chance if it's the only thing
in your day that made you smile a little
bit made you feel like you had a little
bit of hope then I get why they do it
the other reason the other thing I think
of a lot about here is that if you are
in a low-income job and you're working
graveyard shifts and you're exhausted
and you're taking three buses to get
your kids to school if the only thing
that day that gives you a little bit of
pleasure is a cigarette and some alcohol
I get it I totally get it and that's
also the relationship between health and
poverty is a lot of that too so it's
very easy for people who are of higher
means to look down at those people and
point out all the bad decisions that
they're that they're doing in life but I
think you underestimate how much that
desire to just have a little bit of Hope
a little bit of pleasure and if those
feel like your only avenues for Hope and
pleasure maybe that's the explanation
for at least part of it quick one this
is really really fascinating to me on
the back end of our YouTube channel it
says that
69.9% of you that watch this channel
frequently over the lifetime of this
channel haven't yet hit the Subscribe
button I just wanted to ask you a favor
it helps this channel so much if you
choose to just subscribe helps us scale
the guest helps us scale the production
and it makes the show bigger so if I
could ask you for one favor if if you've
watched this show before and you've
enjoyed it and you like this episode
that you're currently watching could you
please hit the Subscribe button thank
you so much and I will repay that
gesture by making sure that everything
we do here gets better and better and
better and better that is a promise I'm
willing to make you do we have a deal
let's speak then to 18-year-old Steve
that was in that little room with the
stack of these what they call County
Court judgments and bays and stuff stack
of letters on his desk what advice based
on all you know about money and finance
can you give to somebody who is maybe
you know making a th $1,000 $2,000 a
month covers their rent just about
doesn't have a lot of money left over
what is the best way to go from that
position to a position of wealth in your
view I think one of the best ways to
think about it at the lower levels and I
explained a little bit this earlier but
to dig into it is a lot of what's
probably giving you stress in life is
that you don't have control over what
you're doing and if you view every
dollar of savings that you have as a bit
of your future that you own and control
then I think that mind shift that
mindset can shift pretty dramatically
and it's like that's that's the ticket
out the ticket out is not a nicer car
it's not a bigger house it's not better
clothes the ticket out is Independence
that's what's going to give you the
better career that's what's going to
make you happier that's what's going to
make you healthier and the only thing
that's going to give you Independence is
having enough money saved up so that you
can choose where you want to live maybe
even what job you want you can choose at
at at some point down the road when you
retire if you get sick it's not just
going to break you immediately having
that dependence is going to take more
weight off your shoulders than anything
else you can do in life save money
that's it that's the the title of that
chapter in the book is save money
because you can't put it any clearer or
Starker like that's that's it he says
there are three types of people those
who
save those who don't think they can save
and those who don't think they need to
save yep three types of people which one
are you those who save those who don't
think they can save and those who don't
think they need to save I tell you what
I've been all three of my life that's
interesting I've always been a saver no
I haven't and see that I think that's
actually very rare that you change who
you are really on the nature nurture
Spectrum I actually think and this is
kind of disappointing to talk about it's
not fun to talk about but on the nature
of nurture Spectrum I think a lot of
money is nature Warren Buffett talks
about the people who have the money mind
which means like either they get it or
they don't and if they get it they get
it instantly and if they don't they'll
get it never at all I I I actually don't
believe in it it's that black and white
Charlie Monger explains it like that he
says
when explaining financial matters to
young people they either get it
instantly or never at all and he's
putting that too starkly I think I don't
think it's that black and white but on
the nature nurture spectrum is it 8020
is it 7030 I think it's probably
something in that range so let me give
you a count a counterargument to that
then so as I said I've been someone that
didn't think he could save because I
didn't have money and I just thought oh
you know but I could have saved in it
looking back now I know I could have
saved I could have saved a small amount
but I didn't see the value in Saving
small numbers I didn't understand the
laws of compounding returns which we'll
definitely talk about I have also been
the person that
saves and I've also been the person who
thought they didn't need to save I've
been all three my Counterpoint to this
goes back to a story that I read from
your early years where two of your
friends died on a ski trip yeah and it
also links to something you said in your
new book same as ever where you speak
about
how sometimes in life
like hitting rock bottom is the greatest
incentive to change our lives yeah so I
put those two things together and go
that moment when you two of your friends
died on a ski trip that you were on when
you were younger it had an impact on
your risk appetite and your attitude
towards and therefore your attitude
towards money yep what what happened
what happened so I grew up skiing in in
laho California and I was a competitive
ski racer right uh so all throughout my
childhood and teenage years I skied 6
days a week 10 months a year all over
the world and it was great there about
12 of us on the squad Valley ski team we
had grown up together and we' spent our
entire lives together and when I was 17
this is in 2001 I was skiing with my two
two of my best friends brandan Allen and
and and Brian Richmond and we would ski
out of bounds which is illegal you're
not supposed to do it we would duck
under the rope that says do not cross
and we'd ski out of bounds because
that's where a lot of the good skiing is
and when we would do this it would spit
us out on this back country road where
we'd have to hitchhike back there's no
chairlift when you ski out of bounds you
have to hitchhike your way back so so we
did it one morning in February 2001 the
three of us did it and when we did it we
triggered a very small Avalanche and I I
remembered it so clearly like I can
still feel it 21 year 22 years later I
can still feel what is like it's the
weirdest sensation of that I've had in
my life because when you get hit by an
avalanche rather than pushing on the
snow to gain traction with your skis the
ground is pushing you so all of a sudden
you're skiing along and you got control
and all a sudden boom you have no
control anymore the the ground is
pushing you around probably similar to
what it feels like if you're standing on
the ground during an earthquake like the
ground's pushing you but it was a pretty
small Avalanche maybe came up to our
knees ended pretty quickly and we kind
of like literally high-fived about it at
the bottom and went about our day we get
back around to the the base Lodge we
hitchike back and brenon and Brian said
they wanted to do it again they wanted
to ski again and I said hey for whatever
reason I I I just didn't want to do it
so I said hey rather than hit checking
back why don't you guys go do it again
and I'll drive my truck around and pick
you up so we said great we made our
plans went our separate ways they went
skiing I went back around to take my
boots off and jump in my truck and go
pick them up 20 30 minutes later I go to
pick them up at the pickup spot and they
weren't there and I knew it only took us
a minute to ski down the hill so 20
minutes later I knew like they they they
weren't coming I I was not worried I
figured that they had already hitch hike
home but so after waiting for another 20
or 30 minutes I just left and I went
back to the lodge I expected them to be
there and they weren't and I still
didn't really worry like we didn't have
cell phones back then and people were
just comfortable being out of touch if
you didn't know where your your buddy
was like wasn't that that wasn't that
big a deal so we went about the day I I
started worrying a little bit I remember
I stopped at Brendan's house and
expected him to be there and he wasn't
there either and I remember calling and
leaving a message on his voicemail and I
remember ending the voicemail by saying
I hope you're okay man those are my last
word I remember that very clearly the
day went on and I think at about 4: or
5:00 Brian's mom called me and she said
Brian never showed up for work today do
you know where he is and I told her what
happened I said we skied the backside of
squa where we'd hit Chik back I was
going to pick him up but they never
showed up and I haven't seen them since
and I also remember so clearly Brian's
mom saying oh my God and hanging up the
phone and that was so like so it's then
we started getting worried we called the
police the police didn't take it very
seriously because they thought ah
they're out at a party they ran off with
a girl for the night like they weren't
worried but we finally got search and
rescue involved and Rescuers of probe
poles frowned brenon and Brian buried
under 6 ft of snow and they were they
had been killed from a massive Avalanche
and so look I think virtually everyone
listening to this I'm sure you to have
lost somebody close to you somebody that
you love so I know the experience was
not unique in that way but it was the
first time that I had experienced loss
and it was the first bad thing that had
ever happened to me in my life so it had
a big impact on me and there were a lot
of takeaways I think at the time I
didn't have the cognitive tools to piece
together what happened or to learn about
what happened like have any sort of
takeaways but as I got older and thought
about it and looking back I put together
all these like realizations of what that
did to me how it changed me and what
were some of the lessons from it too one
that I talk about in the book that I
think about all the time is my decision
to not go with them on a second run was
this completely brainless decision I put
no thought into that decision it was not
a cost benefit analysis I didn't think
through it but it's the most important
decision I've ever made in my life 100%
chance if I was with them I would have
died and I had skied literally thousands
of runs with Brendan and Brian how many
times did I deny a second run with them
or say you guys keep going I'm going to
go in almost never the one time I did it
saved my entire life and so that you
really realize that the world hangs by a
thread everybody thinks like oh you're
going to put a lot of thought into your
big decisions to make sure that you're
successful in life where you go to
college what your career is going to be
who you marry that's all great but the
world hangs by a thread and there are
tiny little no nothing decisions maybe
that you made today of maybe it was when
to cross the street maybe it was when to
leave to get in your car that can
utterly change the course of your life
and so when once you accept that of how
much the world hangs by a thread I think
you become much more humble with your
willingness to make forecasts about the
future what the economy is going to do
who's going to win the election what's
going to happen in my life my career my
family's life we have no clue we have no
idea because all we can think about are
the big decisions we cannot piece
together the chaos theory of I got in my
car at the at the wrong time I met the
wrong person or I met the right person
or you know I I decided not to take a
second run we cannot forecast the impact
of those things and so that had a big
impact on me too of just who are we to
fool ourselves that we can predict the
next recession that we can predict where
our careers are going to be in 10 years
that we can predict how long our
marriage is going to last that we can
predict how long we're going to live we
can't nobody can because we can't
predict how crazy these tiny events can
turn into and this comes right back to
investing doesn't it
because most people that consider
themselves to be investors whether
that's just putting a couple of quid
into crypto or something else engage in
that idea that they can predict the
future yeah um and this is where it
appears that most money is lost I mean
think about the biggest risk to the US
economy over the last two generations
that's one of them the others would be
Pearl Harbor
911 and maybe uh Lan Brothers couldn't
find a buyer in 2008 which sparked the
financial crisis of 2008 those are the
biggest risks by far and the common
denominator of every one of those
stories is that nobody saw them coming
they were not in any newspaper before
they happened they were not in any
economic Outlook nobody was going on TV
warning you that this was coming the
common denominator of those is that they
did all of their damage in two seconds
and that would be thee going forward I
you can guarantee that the biggest news
story and the biggest risk over the next
year or the next 10 years of our life
whatever it is is something that
nobody's talking about today that you
and I have can't even fathom because
it's always been like that there's never
been a time when the biggest news story
was
foreseeable and it's all and it'll be
like that going forward so that's
another just like embracing how fragile
the world is there's a great quote from
a financial adviser who I really admire
named Carl Richards and he says risk is
what's left over when you think you
thought of everything you can go out of
your way to think about all of the risks
that are in your life and like great and
like how you're going to prevent them
great that's a good thing to do when
you're done with that exercise what's
left over that you're not thinking about
is what risk actually is it's like by
definition we can never plan or even
imagine what the biggest risks in our
lives are going to be you say that in
same as ever you say I think the the
chapter title is risk is the things you
can't see or something risk is what you
don't see risk is what you don't see
that was a little bit terrifying and
it's true and I think I think sometime
you can phrase it as terrifying it's
also kind of relieving that like why are
you going to put so much effort into
trying to predict what the stock
market's going to do next what the
econom is going to do next why are you
building a forecasting model to figure
out what the economy is going to do over
the next 10 years when you look at the
last 10 or 20 years how could you ever
predict 911 or coid and even look like
something like Co there's like a 2015
Bill Gates Ted Talk where he talks about
the biggest risk to Society is a viral
pandemic so it's not that nobody saw
that thing coming but the specifics of
when it's going to happen how bad it's
going to be is it just going to shut
down the economy for a week or two years
that is completely impossible but
there's also lots of other TED Talks
that say everything's going to be great
of course of course there's prob there's
a lot more so on balance the world had
no idea I think on balance the world
breaks once per decade not exactly once
per DEC but on average once per decade
everything that you thought about risk
and uncertainty and stability goes to
[__] so how do I prepare if risk if risk
is what I don't see how do I prepare
there's another great quote from Nasim
talb that I like where he says invest in
preparedness not in prediction so rather
than going out of your way to be like
here's what I think is going to happen
in crypto here's what I think is going
to happen in the stock market just make
sure that you have a big enough buffer
in your finances cash liquidity being
scared of debt so that no matter what
happens you're you at least have a
Fighting Chance of enduring it and
making through one thing I've I've often
thought about is that you should have
enough cash in your investing portfolio
the amount of cash you should have
should feel like it's too much it should
feel it should make you wise a little
bit because if you only have enough cash
to put up with the risk that you can
Envision and the risk that you can
foresee you're going to miss a surprise
every single time every single surprise
is going to be a surprise to you but if
you feel like you have too much cash
then at least you have a Fighting Chance
of putting up with the 911 the coid the
Pearl Harbor whatever it might be so
when people look at my asset allocation
my investments a lot of people look at
it and say you seem really conservative
why do you have this much cash what are
you saving for and my answer is always I
don't know I have no idea what I'm
saving for who are we to assume that we
can predict the risks that are going to
be in our own personal lives and
throughout the broader World nobody can
do it the only way to prepare for it is
to have what feels like too much safety
what is is your Capital allocation
strategy how do you invest your money um
this is you know this is the thing
people want to know most about you I
keep it as painfully simple as I
possibly can so literally my entire net
worth is cash a house and index funds
and some shares of marel or I'm on the
board of directors and that's it there's
nothing else my entire I can summarize
everything so easily and so cleanly and
truly that's it it's not even like I
have 20 bank accounts I I have one bank
account one brokerage account like in a
house and that's it it's so simple why
why index funds you're the reason I your
Capital allocation strategy is almost
identical to mine I want to talk about
the housing as well but um after reading
your book I stopped trying to pick
stocks yeah and I invested all of my
available Capital into index funds
outside of investing it in starting
companies so I'm a shareholder in I
don't know 50 60 70 companies I all my
other available capital is invested in
index funds and then I have a very
longstanding standing large position in
ethereum which I've held for like six
years or something which has done me
very well yeah that is it and the
ethereum investment is also based on the
fact that I run a software business that
is in blockchain and I could see that
developers are building on top of
ethereum more than any other blockchain
so that Insight was really beneficial to
me and six years so even with the big
fall of the last two years you're still
up a lot yeah I I think your book taught
me that successful in investing is when
you lose the password to your investment
account yes that's exactly it I don't
actually think you said that in there
but that's like when I lose the password
to my investment account I'm so proud of
myself because it means I haven't
checked it in
forever and so it was funny because you
were coming today I thought oh yeah well
I have all this money in these index
funds I'll check it and I thought [__] I
don't know the password good that's why
you're going to do okay the reason I do
this what's important is that I am not
one of the people who says nobody can
beat the market so therefore use index
funds that's not what I believe I think
there I think it's extreme hard to beat
the market and very few people will do
it but I think there are really smart
people who can do it and people who I
know who I could invest with the reason
I don't is not because I don't believe
it can be done it's because the variable
that I want to maximize for in my
investments is endurance if I can just
earn average returns for an above
average period of time it's going to
lead to amount of success that will
literally put you in the top 5% of
investors my parents are a great example
of this my parents are smart people but
they really they have no fin background
and they have like minimal financial
interest I would say and but they have
dollar cost average into index funds for
going on 40 years now and literally if
you look at their returns they've never
sold anything ever and literally if you
look at the returns they'd probably be
in the top 3% of professional investors
what is for anyone that doesn't know
what is dollar cost averaging and what
is an index fund dollar cost averaging
means you buy the same dollar amount of
Investments every single month come hell
or high water doesn't matter what the
stock market's doing recession boom bust
you say I'm going to going to put $100
or whatever it is in the stock mark on
the first of every month now most people
who like have a 401k at work are doing
this whether they know it or not they
have $100 or whatever removed from every
paycheck and it goes into the funds that
they own and they don't have to do
anything whether you know it or not
you're actually doing it the contrast to
that would say I'm G to buy and sell
based off of how I feel in the stock
market I wake up I watch CNBC I decided
to sell and I'm going to put it back in
when I feel better about the market it's
the contrast of that an index fund is
just a single fund that owns hundreds or
thousands of stocks within it and if
it's diverse enough if it's big enough
really what you're doing is you're
owning a slice of the global economy
which is how I think about it it's
thousands of individual stocks in there
Tesla Apple whatever it would be but
really what you're doing is you're
owning a slice of capitalism if I was
your son and I said Dad prove to me that
that's a better long-term wealth
creation strategy than buying crypto or
buying companies that I use or like how
would you explain that to your to your
kid your ability to do well over the
next one year or 5 years is going to
have no role whatsoever on your lifetime
ability to generate wealth all that's
going to matter is not what are the best
returns you can earn all that matters
are is what are the returns that you can
sustain for the longest period of time
all that matters is your endurance it
doesn't matter if you can double your
money this year or even double your
money again the next year all that
matters is can you stick and keep it
going for 50 years that's where
compounding comes from prove it all
because the formula for compounding is
returns to the power of time that's not
quite it but like more or less that's it
so in that equation if you understand
the math all of the heavy lifting comes
from the exponent prove it because
that's how exponential growth works
that's how it works it's literally
exponential give me a case study where
someone has followed that strategy and
done well okay here's one way to explain
it that I use in the book
99% of Warren Buffett's net worth was
accumulated after his 60th
birthday after he turned 60 years old
99% of his wealth Jesus has been
accumulated after that period because
the longer you hold that four the
crazier the numbers get when he was 60 I
think he was worth about $3 billion lot
of money it's a multi-billionaire but
now that he's 90 he's worth over hundred
billion and he's given like a 100
billion away to charity so if he didn't
do that he'd be worth he'd go from three
billion to2 200 billion since he's been
60 because the numbers just get crazier
at that point he's worth a hundred
billion doar so if his if his Market if
his net worth goes up 10% in one year he
makes1 billion which is three times that
he was worth when he was 60 so that's
when you look at somebody like Buffett
is he a great investor is he a great
stock picker of course but the real
secret to his success is that he's been
a good investor for 80 years and if he
had retired at age 60 or at age 50
nobody would have ever heard of him he
would have been like one of the other
multi-billionaires who lives in Florida
and plays golf and like you you've never
heard of him the reason he's a household
name is because he's been doing this
non-stop since he's since he's been 11
years old and he's never stopped it's
just the endurance that's made him so
wealthy not necessarily the annual
returns patience it's a difficult thing
it also reminds me of the story that you
talk about in the introduction of your
book about the janitor Ronald James Reed
yeah who when he died in 2014 age 92 had
a net worth of over 8
million and he was a janitor how did he
do that he took what very little money
he could save from his job as a janitor
mopping floors at the gas station he put
it in stocks and he left it alone for 70
years and that's it that's all you need
that's all you need to do if you have
endurance in your investing and you can
keep it going for years or decades you
don't need to be a genius stock picker
and now do not need to do it if you have
endurance you're going to beat literally
97 or 99% of the genius stock Pickers
and what's so interesting about it is
like picking the right stocks is hard
it's supposed to be hard like there's no
world in which everybody who tries to
beat the market is going to do it of
course it's hard just like being an NBA
player is hard and but having endurance
is like largely in your control it's so
much easier to just be patient than it
is to pick the right stocks every single
day now I think some people nature
nurture some people like probably Ronald
Reed and my parents Ju Just understand
it naturally it's not hard for them to
be patient but do like there are
professional investors who work 80 hours
a week for 30 years to try to beat the
market and they can't do it not only
some that that explains like most of
them and even the ones who can do it are
maybe going to beat the market by half a
percent per year 1% per year but if you
can have endurance that is that's a
bigger benefit than you can have by even
being like a very successful stock
picker like somebody who outperforms the
market by one percentage Point per year
and they can do that for 10 years that's
amazing that's like Mount Rushmore
investor but somebody who earns average
returns and does it for 20 years is
going to have way more money you do it
for 30 years you're going to be Filthy
Rich You' be like Ronald Reed you can be
a janitor who leaves $8 million to
charity when you die but so in the case
of Ronald Reed you're not looking at him
a little bit and go listen bro if you
had eight or9 million in the bank you
should have been living it up see this
is one I I do kind of regret that in the
book that I'm I kind of I didn't say it
explicitly but I kind of make him out to
be a role model and I don't think that's
the case he's not my role model I think
he's a fascinating story of somebody who
became Rich despite not having any of
the pedigree or any of the skills that
you are normally associated with wealthy
people but you're right that he lived in
a a
squalid housing and he worked as a
janitor that's not my goal so I I I want
to live a nice life I want to be
independent but he's the most extreme
example that you can come up with and I
I I wish I had stated that more clearly
in the book A lot of people have this
conversation around pensions and in the
UK we we can pay money from our salary
into our pension but I think a lot of
people think gosh when I'm 60 when I'm
65 I want to be rich I want to be rich
when I'm 25 yeah and I can go to Vegas
and you know ball out and buy nice
things and have great experiences not
when I'm 65 yeah no I think that's true
I think there are a lot of people a lot
of financial advisers will say that one
of the hardest things they do as an
adviser is getting their clients to
spend money because they've been so
conditioned to save save save save save
that when they finally retire at 65 they
don't know how to spend they have no
clue how to spend money there's a great
uh author I think you've had him on your
show RIT Siti who talks about this a lot
like how you like you need to learn how
to live a a rich life and figure out
what that is for you for some like for
me it's just like my my happy state is
like sitting on the couch in sweatpants
reading a book going for a walk with my
wife that's that's that's my rich life
that I love doing and to do that I need
to be independent and autonomous so I
can do that all day long I can do that
on a Wednesday afternoon rid talks a lot
about like maybe your rich life I think
for him it's flying first class and
wearing nice clothes and he talks about
like he drives I think like a beat up
Honda but he flies first class and he
dresses very nicely so you just have to
figure out what is the little thing
that's going to make you happy and I
think a lot of people's problem is that
Society tells you what you're supposed
to do to be happy you're supposed to
have a nice car supposed to have a big
house supposed to wear nice clothes
that's what Society tells you to do and
for some people that might be the case
for other people like me I think it it's
not that's that that would not ever make
me happy what does make me happy is
Independence so I can just do these
little quirky things that I like to do
so I think you just have to figure out
the little things that make you happy
rather than just being forced by Society
into what they want you to do knowing
when enough is enough this was one of
the most interesting things that I think
really rang true to me was how do I know
in my life when enough is enough I've
definitely been a victim to that
external narrative that I need to have
these things in my life to be a happy
person but how does one go about knowing
when enough is enough I think back to
the story of my father he just woke up
one day and it was obvious that he would
he had been doing what he did for long
enough and it was he had felt like he
had enough and what not and he and he
broke away from it I
think for for a lot of people it's just
I one thing that's important about the
concept of having enough in Independence
is that when most people even if they
are independent they wake up every
morning what they want to do is go to
work one of one of the big problems with
the fire movement the financial
Independence retire early movement where
people are like they're going to be a
Super Saver and then retire at age 31
whatever it' be so many of those people
who actually did that and retired at age
31 they once they retired after about 2
weeks they were bored out of the mind
and if they did it for 6 months they
were clinically depressed cuz for most
people you want to be productive you
want to keep doing it so having enough
doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to stop working it just means
you're going to keep doing only the work
that you want to do there's a really
interesting question that Patrick oesi
asks a lot of people uh in in his office
he says if you won a billion dollars in
the lottery but you had to stay at this
job you're a billionaire but you can't
quit what if this company would you want
to do and what would you get rid of
and virtually everyone has an answer for
that question they say oh if I didn't
need the money but I have to stay I
would love to work on this project I
love working on this thing this that and
the other is all [__] to me so like
in any job there's going to be something
that you want to do there's going to be
some project there's be some position or
or or maybe it's like being an artist
whatever it would be it's not that you
stop working it's that when you have
enough you get to pick and choose which
of those things you going to end up
doing it's often too late in our lives
when we realize the cost that we've paid
for enough never been enough you know it
could be family it could be Health
whatever um I always reflect on the with
Brony wear wasn't it who interviewed
people on their deathbeds and found out
that the biggest regret of the dying was
not living a life true to themselves
working too much Etc but that's on your
deathbed there's nothing you can do at
that point right and I think a lot about
this like what am I going to regret yes
I think about that too I think this is
this is pretty morbid to think about but
I think about if I were on my deathbed
tomorrow would I regret working hard and
saving a lot of money and my answer is
absolutely not it would give me so much
pleasure to know that my wife and my two
young kids are going to be fine and the
opposite of that I cannot fathom being
on my deathbed and looking at my wife
and my eight-year-old son and my
four-year-old daughter and thinking you
guys are screwed that would that that
would that would be the biggest regret I
can fathom so I think a lot of people
would look at someone with a high
savings rate like me and would assume
that I'm going to regret it on my
deathbed and who knows but I I I have to
think it would actually be the opposite
what makes me gives me so much happiness
and pleasure is taking care of my family
and if I were to go to tomorrow I
wouldn't regret for one second the car
that I didn't buy the big house I didn't
buy the nice clothes I didn't buy not
for a second would I regret not doing
those it's a really good frame to Think
Through isn't it about our financial
decision- making and you know a lot of
people like saving up to buy a lot of
nonsense that's going to depreciate and
would you rather have a little Nest Egg
left over for the ones you love or buy
that Lamborghini there's another great
book called die was Zero which basically
the title is self-explanatory and one of
the concepts is even if you want to give
money away to your family don't wait
until you die don't make your kids wait
or like hope you're going to die so they
can get their inheritance give it to
them when it really matters which for
most people is in their 30s and 40s if
you wait until you die at age 90 and
your kids are 60 and then they get your
money like what's the purpose of that
give it to them when they need it when
they're raising kids and whatnot that's
when they need your money I I I really
like that concept I think about that
with my own kids the Counterpoint to
that is though if I just give my kids
money then like the ch
quote they might lose it quick just
think about that especially as you know
someone that has a lot of cash they
could give I think about this because at
some point I'm going to have kids and
they're going to Daddy I want to do a
driving lesson or they're going to be 18
and go off to University or whatever God
I hope they don't go to university um
and they're going to say like I've got
nowhere to live or I found this nice
apartment dad and in those moments do I
make the decision to pay for it because
I can or withhold it because they need
to learn the hard way I have this yeah
call it an argument with my girlfriend
where I say babe listen when we have
kids they're going to sit in economy and
she's like absolutely not yeah and I'm
like no babe when they get okay we made
a deal I think we got to about when
they're 12 years old I'm going to put
them in economy so they can learn for
themselves the value of things see we we
made this mistake I don't think I've
ever talked about this but it was about
a year ago we flew my son who was me I
guess he was seven at the time we flew
first class and we explained to him that
this was not normal this was not going
to be the way it is as soon as he did it
he went home he told all of our
neighbors told all of his friends told
everybody at school and that was when my
like can't can't do this never again you
see how quickly somebody can be spoiled
or use that to try to show other people
that they are superior to them that's
when it was like no no we can't ever do
this ever again and you moved his
expectations in a way absolutely I
didn't fly first class till I was 35 and
he did it at 7 and so that my when I
first did it at 35 I remember feeling a
I earned this I worked for this and it
also felt so special to me because I'd
flown coach 9,000 times before that so
it felt amazing and so that's I I I
think about that a lot there's a great
quote from Charlie Munger where one of
his rich friends says Charlie if I give
my kids all of my money is that going to
ruin their ambition and Charlie says of
course it will but you have to do it
anyways and the guy says why and Charlie
says because if you don't your kids will
hate you and I think that's that too is
like lots of Charlie Monger quotes are
are framed as black and white they're
but I think that's probably like 80%
true really that it's it's maybe 70%
true that if you are a wealthy person
and I'm not talking billionaires if you
just have a moderate amount of wealth
that you might pass along to your kids
someday that your two options are kind
of at least to some extent hurt their
ambition or risk some level of strife
and it's always child dependent like I
always make the example that if
18-year-old Bill Gates or Mark
Zuckerberg or Elon Musk inherited a
billion dollars would have made any
difference to their ambition they would
they would not have slowed them down by
one second but most people including
myself it would have like I was driven
by fear of not making it which is what
most people are I was I was scared
shitless that I was not going to find
the right career that I wasn't going to
make it and that's what drove me some
people don't need that but I think it's
very rare I think the huge majority of
people if you give them an easy life
they will take it and embrace it with
both hands making money and keeping
money require two different
skills you you've spoken about a few of
the skills that are required for making
money the one that really stuck out to
me that you've discussed so far is this
idea of endurance patience regardless of
what's happening in the markets
regardless of the volatility lose your
password and sit on your hands just on
that point as well I remember reading
somewhere it might have even been your
book you know it's so crazy because the
things that I know about money I can't
remember where I've got them from but
most of them came from this book like
most of the principles came from this
book and one of the things that I read
was that Warren Buffett would go like
five years without allocating capital
and this quote where he said the hardest
thing to be a great investor is to be
able to sit on your hands and do nothing
sit on your ass and do nothing that's it
that's that's AER quote and that's what
they're doing right now right now
Berkshire hathway which is Warren
Buffett's company has like $150 billion
dollar of cash right now and that's
their entire uh 60-year history of
Warren Buffett and Brookshire hathway is
build up a shitload of cash wait 10
years for an opportunity deploy it all
and then go back to waiting and building
up cash crazy and that's that's that's
how done it good opportunities are rare
of course they are they should be rare
it shouldn't be that anybody can just
open up their stock account and find the
opportunity of a lifetime what are the
it's GNA come once a decade what are the
other skills then endurance patience to
create to get money for the for the
ordinary person endurance and patience
is 99% of what you need as an investor
because the opportunities there to
invest in a lowcost Index Fund are
available for everybody and you can do
that from your phone like you do it from
your phone open up a Robin Hood account
buy some index funds anybody can do that
and so that and but that was not always
the case it used to be like 20 years ago
that the only people who could invest
were people who had a lot of money and
could afford a broker and had connection
to a broker and yet to like make a phone
call make a phone call you had to know a
guy and even then you were going to pay
a ridiculous fee to that person for do
pieces of paper and all kinds H it was a
joke and that's 20 years ago it's not
that long ago so I think like people
aren't grateful enough or appreciative
enough of how much things have changed
that open up those opportunities for
everybody you talk about the skill of
keeping money which is different from
the skill of getting money
is predicated on Survival Financial
survival and just putting up with all
the unpredictable nonsense that's going
to happen between now and the end of
your life and we talked earlier about
the surprises Pearl Harbor 911 all these
big surprises just it's just your
ability to endure things like that
that's going to be literally 90% of your
financial success and your investing
success so gaining money is like being
an optimist and taking a risk like being
optimistic about yourself swinging for
the fences you need that to get rich
staying rich is like the exact opposite
you need a level of being conservative
you need to be scared you need to be
like owledge of all the unknown risks
that are in front of us and have a
financial allocation and a mindset
that's going to allow you to endure them
and survive them financially you need
both of those skills at the same time so
well your kid is 20 years old he's broke
do you tell him to go and take huge
outsized risks he's not got a family
he's not got a mortgage he's not got a
dog what advice do you give him at that
age to create wealth I would actually
say I think this is a little
counterintuitive that when somebody is
Young you you think you would say you
got 50 years in front of you swing for
the fences go for it it's also when your
life is the most fragile it's when
you're most likely to be laid off most
likely to change your career most likely
to break up or get divorced whatever it
would be and so for that you need quite
a bit of financial flexibility just cash
and liquidity so once you had some level
built up whatever the level might be for
a different person then like do
something crazy I also think like for
careers some of the best career advice
that's maybe not Universal but when you
graduate college and you looking at your
career don't take the safe job which is
usually like the big company the blue
chick company go for the weird company
why go for something crazy because when
you're older when you're 40 and you have
two kids and a mortgage you're not going
to want to take the weird job that's
when you want the stability that's when
you're probably going to want the job
that's has good benefits and a stable
paycheck cuz you need that when you're
22 and you're not tied down by anything
don't go work for Goldman Sachs or apple
or deoe or something like that go for
the weird startup where you like you're
going to learn something completely
different linked to that point is in the
weird startup you're going to be so
close to the failure and failure is the
knowledge you're going to learn so much
and there's so many people who take the
blue chip the safe job out of college
and it puts them on a very predictable
track you're going to be an analyst for
two years and then if you're good you'll
get promoted to senior analyst and then
you'll get promoted to associate it's
like very stable and linear and that's
the like it's you're capping all of your
upside if you go for the weird company
you're either going to do one of two
things it's either going to fail and
you're going to learn a lot from that or
it's going to take off and you're going
to learn a lot from that and then maybe
when you're 40 after going through all
that then you want the stable job at the
big company it's interesting I was
thinking as you're speaking that the
proximity from your desk and the
CEOs probably needs to widen over time
yes I think I think that's that's true
yeah absolutely and most people I think
if they if you do it the other way
around or most people would never do it
the other way around if you start your
career in the stable company you're
probably never going to leave you're
going to get addicted to the nice
paycheck the stable benefits whatnot and
you're never going to take a risk and do
anything else maybe that's okay maybe
for some people's personalities that's
exactly what they want but I think there
is a higher level of regret for people
that start in a safe company and then
they get the golden handcuffs they can't
leave and by the time they're 40 and
they realize that they wanted to work at
the crazy company they can't because
they got a mortgage and two kids and
they're saving for retirement and they
can't take the risk at that level of
their life you introduced this concept
of
tales long tales and this also changed
my life changed my investment strategy I
should probably say you talk about the
example of venture capital where for
every 50 Investments That Venture
capitalists make statistically half of
them will completely fail 10 will do
okay and one or two will make huge
profits that drive 100% of the funds
returns yeah this is a lesson about
invest in finance but it's also for me a
lesson about life it's always life yeah
it applies to everything tals where just
a couple of things that happen explain
90 or 99% of what matters it's always
the case you see it in business where
you take in the United States there are
you know thousands of public companies
you can buy stock in but the huge
majority of the value in the US Stock
Market is in like 10 companies Apple
Tesla Microsoft so even though you have
thousands of companies 10 of them are
the ones that really matter and are
going to drive all of the returns over
time so why you just buy those 10
because nobody knows what they're going
to be at least in hindsight that that
that's the argument for owning a
thousand of them is that you know that
the 10 that are going to be the next big
ones are going to be in there all of
this is a case for humility this is
honestly what I took away from your book
you're expecting to walk away with tips
all these tips these tricks these
special ways to make more money than
everybody what I came away with is this
one important lesson that I've never
been able to unsee which is I don't know
I I think that's great and then back to
I wrote this book for myself that's been
the biggest lesson for me is not only do
I know but nobody else knows either
everyone everyone else is bullshitting
their way through the investing Market
too they don't know either I'm in this
crypto chat where one of my friends I
won't disparage him one of my friends
he's the guy in the chat that's always
posting the forecast graphs you know
those ones where they kind of like the
little loger graphs where they forecast
where the stock or the crypto is go
where think it's going to go right and
it's always it's always up and to the
right um and it's kind of like male
horoscopes I heard someone say that that
that's such a great yeah no I think
that's I think what's closest to
investing is something like the
horoscope where even if you know it's
[__] you want to read it why because
it's comforting what a lot of people
want out of their investing forecasts or
whatever it is is they want to reduce
the uncertainty that's giving them
stress because everyone I think
intuitively knows that the future in
front of us is unknown and it's
unknowable but that hurts and so if it
hurts you try to reduce that stress by
finding someone who says I do know
what's going to happen you know what
this applies as well is I read Amazon's
Jeff Bezos who's the CEO and founder of
Amazon his shareholder letter where he
says we have to be the best place in the
world to fail um we swing for the fences
10 times and for every 10 swings nine of
them are in the Amazon graveyard he's
talking there about a9.com which nobody
knows because failed the fir phone which
nobody knows but the one in 10 pay for
the entirety of the graveyard the one in
is going to be AWS 7 billion this year
right he talked about that when the fire
phone from Amazon which if you don't
know Amazon built a cell phone it's
called the fire phone and it was a joke
it was a disaster it was a massive flop
and he was doing like an analyst call
and his analyst talked about like hey
the Fire Phone flopped like what
happened there and bezo said if you
think that was a big failure just wait
you've seen nothing yet and like that's
why Amazon's successful they're willing
to try a thousand things with the idea
that they know 990 of them are going to
fail but the 10 that work are going to
be massive and if you can fail well and
have the mentality to fail and the
financial backing to be able to fail
like make sure your bets are not that
big and you can just keep taking little
risks all the time the optionality that
you get from that like the odds that one
or two of those are going to explode are
huge it's massive and mean it's no
different than how do you win the
lottery you have to buy thousands and
thousands or millions of tickets if you
buy billions of tickets you'll probably
win the lottery it's probably not going
to pay off because it doesn't work like
that but it's the same concept like if
you if you if you take enough swings at
bat one of them is going to hit
eventually and this is also
a reason why some companies look
Innovative they look like their Geniuses
but in fact their failure rate is
massive massive there's a story at at
Netflix several years ago where there
was uh a report to the CEO and the and
the report was all of the new movies
that we've come out that that we've that
we've produced have been successful and
whoever presented that probably thought
this is great this is what you want to
hear and the CEO said that's terrible
that means we're not taking enough risks
if every movie that we release is a hit
we're not taking risks like you want
your failure rate to be at least some
that that's when you know you're at
least trying something new it's the same
like if you're managing uh a hotel you
don't want every room to be sold out
because that means you're not pricing
high enough you know you're doing a good
job when you have 10 empty rooms that's
when you know you're pricing the other
rooms at a high enough rate so there's
always going to be like some level of
what looks like failure that you need
and if you don't have it you're not
taking a big enough risk Daniel X sat
here and he said the same thing he goes
one of the most important metrics that I
think about at Spotify is our mistake
rate yeah and people will think okay so
he wants to limit mistakes very much the
opposite he wants to make sure that the
company maintains that sort of startup
mentality and they increase their rate
of mistakes and this brings me to
something which I kind of hit me like a
truck um in your new book same as ever
which was this idea that we need to keep
running now there were areas in my
professional life where I've been
successful poas is doing well I think
doing pretty well and I had a I had a
car Journey with Jima who's through the
wall who you met and we last time we
came to La I'm in the front seat of the
car and I go jamim do you know what our
biggest um our biggest threat is now
complacency when people get successful
they play defense to their detriment um
they don't play offense as much as they
need to to keep up with the rate of
change in the world and then a young
Scrappy agile incumbent who has a high
risk appetite will take their cheese
right and your chapter on keep running
there's two quotes that I really pulled
out chapter's called keep running and
and the quot two quotes that I pulled
out were competitive advantages tend to
be shortlived often because their
success plants the seeds of their own
decline one more quote it's easy to
overlook how many forces pull you away
from your competitive Advantage once you
have one specifically because you have
one success has its own gravity that's
right and the the the the biggest source
of gravity there is laziness the reason
you're successful is because you work so
hard to get to where you were and now
that you feel like you've made it now
that you feel like you're on the top of
the mountain top you get lazy and that's
so many companies fall for that so many
careers fall for that there's a great
story from Jerry Seinfeld where he said
that one of the reasons that he quit the
show when it was still going gang
busters is because he could start to
sense that what made the show successful
was starting to be just starting to go
away he said and part of the reason is
was because he got so famous when he was
not that famous he could go sit in a
coffee shop and watch how people ordered
their coffee and make a joke out of it
he was observing how Society worked once
he got very famous he couldn't do that
anymore he was too famous to go sit in a
deli and watch how people order their
sandwiches he couldn't do it so
therefore he didn't have a lot of the
source material that he had before and
so he was like look what made me so
funny and the show so successful I can't
do anymore so like red alert let's pull
the plug before it gets really bad here
so that's like a very specific example
but what he realized that what made him
successful was gone and a lot of a lot
of CEOs will will have this problem too
where what made them successful was that
they were a scrappy startup founder and
they were very good at building a
product but now that the company is big
and successful they also need to be an
HR Manager they need to be a finance
specialist they need to be a marketer
they need to be all these other things
and therefore their time is pulled away
from what they're actually good at which
is building a product my good example of
this if I can say it was Travis kalanick
of uber the founder of uber probably
nobody in the world was better at
scaling a company like uber than he than
he was and there were a few people who
were worse at managing a big company
than he was so it's like what made Uber
successful is what pulled him away from
being a successful manager at that he
was very good at one thing he was the
best in the world at that one thing but
you shouldn't think that like it's going
to last during when another phase of the
company's life my person I consider a
mentor and a friend of mine been a
long-term friend of mine a guy called
Shaquille Khan he was one of the very
first investors in shop in Spotify um
new Daniel the founder from the very
Beginnings he said to me um a piece of
advice that stayed with me and I've also
imparted on other people at a time when
I'd left my company I was now
financially successful um financially
free by all regards and I called him
after leaving my company and I said D I
said Shaq what should I do now with my
life he said to me Stephen the reason
you were successful was because you were
hungry you need to realize that you're
no longer hungry for the same reasons
yeah and what he told me to do was the
hardest [__] thing I've ever done in
my life which was nothing he said spend
a year don't rush back into starting the
same business again cuz he said to me
the reason why you were so unbelievably
disciplined and would go to the office s
days a week was because you were like an
insecure kid that was like fighting to
survive that's gone now so sit on your
hands for a year do absolutely nothing
and get inspired again get get hungry
again about something new um because my
Temptation was just to run back in and
start a big marketing business again or
whatever yeah I that's kind of what
you're you're speaking of as well is
that like the need to understand that
our motivations evolve and change over
time and the thing that made us
successful might not be the thing that
makes us successful again in a new
Venture I think there are some people
who really can keep it going some people
who do keep running like El [__]
perfect example guys worth a quarter of
a trillion dollars it still works 100
hours a week so there are those people
who exist but I think for a lot of
people this should not be a scary thing
the fact that after you've made it and
have some success and some some wealth
that you're not as hungry as you used to
be that's fine just you just have to
accept it it gets dangerous when people
don't realize it and they they are less
hungry they're not as motivated but
they're still going to try to go start a
new business even though they don't need
it anymore and then they're shocked when
that business doesn't work he said to me
you need to take on a moonshot and
because he know he goes you did the
first business you did well whatever Etc
he goes the thing that will make you
hungry and sufficiently terrified is you
now need to find a big scary terrifying
goal that's what Elon did with Twitter
yeah he'd already become the richest man
in the world and he probably got bored a
little bit and he said I need to do
something that's crazy and that even for
someone like me is going to be an
absolute stretch to pull off crazy which
is buying Twitter and running into the
ground I mean there's no surprise that
billionaires will seem to start rocket
companies yeah I mean the reason that
they are successful is because they have
that complete swing for the fences I
mean most people would quit full stop
when their net worth hit 10 million or
less 3 million and so for someone to
have a net worth of 10 billion and to
wake up and say I'm going to keep going
as hard as I possibly can that's why
they have that level of success it's
complete insatiable Hunger for More I
sat with a billionaire when I was
20 going to say 24 years old and I sat
in his office and I thought okay this is
going to be really interesting I get to
meet this very successful person in
Manchester and I looked into his eyes
and said why are you doing this like you
have all of this money and it became
completely apparent to me that it was
not about the money it was all about
competition I then went and met another
billionaire who was in Manchester runs
another big company Manchester everybody
knows the company and it was the same
thing with him it was the thing that had
got him to a billion was the thing that
was going to keep him going after a
billion yeah I mean there's there's a
chapter in my book about natural Maniacs
like people like wild Minds people the
kind of person like Elon Musk who has
that mindset to say you know when he was
30 years old or whatever he took on GM
Ford Chrysler and NASA when he was like
30 the kind of person who thinks that is
not the kind of person who's going to
say I have enough I'm going to put it
all in Muni bonds and go live on the
farm like it's not the person who thinks
they can do that and can pull that off
is the kind of person who's never going
to stop if Elon Must List till he's 97
he's going to be starting new rocket
companies for sure do you think he's
happy no absolutely none I think most
people in that situation the word that I
would use is tortured I think they wake
up every morning tortured at the
problems that they are aspiring to solve
that they haven't solved yet there's
almost no biography of a very successful
person like that of that level of
success that you would read their
biography and say that life sounds great
it's one of the things that hit me like
a train truck was those two billionaires
I met were just the most miserable
people absolutely and I met their their
one of their sons and they go dad is so
unhappy I remember him saying that to me
and just go [__] he's going to that
office every single day has a billion
dollars and his kids think he's like sad
there's this amazing story do you
remember um Myspace back in the day
before before Facebook and the guy who
ran it his name was Tom I forget his
last name but when you signed up for
Myspace Tom was your first follow he was
the founder of Myspace and every he
followed everybody and he sold mypace I
think to Qualicom maybe no I'm sorry he
sold he sold Myspace to Viacom and uh
did pretty well let's say I'm guessing
let's say he made $50 million it's
probably something in in in in that
range it's it's probably nothing that's
500 was it maybe he sold the company for
that much but it was it was it was it
was a good but not extraordinary sum of
money and you can see his life on
Instagram it's not exaggeration he's
like travels around the world with his
girlfriend hiking in Bali it looks like
at least from Instagram he lives this
amazing life and then think about Mark
Zuckerberg who is like every year hauled
before Congress where he's like screamed
at for causing all of society's ills and
he has so much on his shoulders and
Facebook stock fell 70% last year
because everyone thinks it's going to
hell and like it looks like a very
stressful incredible amount of pressure
on his shoulders if you were to ask me
which one of those lives would I take
would I rather be someone with $50
million who was traveling around the
world hiking in Bali with my wife or
would I be worth a hundred billion
dollars and wake up every morning scared
shitless with so much pressure on my
shoulders for me it's obvious I'd much
rather be Tom than Mark but that
pressure is a drug in the sense that
when I say the pressure is a drug I mean
we know from motivation psychology and I
mean I think I saw on the back of your
your book yeah Daniel H pink yep Daniel
pink told me that when people aren't
sufficiently challenged they lose
motivation and their level of challenge
kind of increases so to be engaged with
a task you need to um and you think of
this like game psychology the levels
need to get harder and harder for you to
be engaged that's why every game we play
it's not on level one over and over and
over again we need it to go to level two
crosswords get more difficult we stay
engaged do you not think that's the case
with like a big famous CEO that their
engagement appetite their challenge
appetite just grows and that's the only
way they can stay engaged solve bigger
problems I think if you look at someone
like Bill Gates I think he had figured
out business and in 2000 he he
effectively quit Microsoft but he
immediately moved on to what I think was
in his mind a bigger problem which was
like how do I give this money away
effectively and how do I eradicate
malaria those kind of problems and so
even for someone like him who was able
to extract himself from the business
they immediately move on to something
that I think in his mind was more
problematic and a bigger challenge so
there's never going to be a period where
someone like that were to say I've had
enough I'm just going to retire to read
books like that will never be the case
it's always going to be I think they're
addicted to the challenge is what it is
yeah and I think I I think I am I think
I think everybody is to some extent and
the muss and the gates those people are
extreme examples of it but every I think
everybody needs a minimum level of
stress in their life and the irony is
that we all kind of dream about like
what can I do to eliminate the stress so
I just wake up in Nirvana every day and
you can't everyone needs to have some
sort of conflict Strife challenge stress
in their life and for I think for a lot
of people if they don't get it from real
places they just make up fake problems
in their life that's that's a big
problem with people if for people who
richer people who have a lot of things
they will start worrying and stressing
about the most minute things because
they need that stress in their life on
that point as well just popping back to
we were talking about the complacency
the other thing that I think successful
people become a victim of is their own
correctness I think about that with me
like I've been right about several
decisions in a row so surely that
creates evidence that I'm probably right
again and that can be your downfall as
well or what a lot of it is is you were
right on this topic and then therefore
you assume that you're going to be right
on another topic and you didn't know the
role luck might have played you didn't
know what luck would play but let's say
you a very successful investor and then
and they'll say you're like massively
successful a lot of those people will
think they for I can also be an
effective politician therefore I can
also be an expert on Co whatever it
would be because they think they're so
smart in this area that they must be
smart in other areas a lot of doctors
have this problem with investing where
they think I'm a doctor I'm very
successful I got a PhD from a great
school therefore I can pick the stocks
because I'm a smart person and that
level of overconfidence is their undoing
can success I think your book one of the
key things that stayed with me and I
didn't need to recap myself on was the
stories you told about people that
accurately predicted what was going to
happen in the stock market against all
conventional wisdom they all from what I
recall they went on to lose their money
eventually anyway a lot of them yeah
yeah what is that story you told in your
book there's a story about a guy named
Jesse Livermore who was back in the
1920s he was the most successful
investor in the world and what's so
amazing about Jesse Livermore is that I
think four different occasions in his
life he became the equivalent of a
billionaire adjusted for inflation and
then went bankrupt four separate times
in his life so he was a person who was
like better at anyone in the world at
making money and had no skill whatsoever
at keeping money and that's someone who
like even when he became at one point he
was the richest man in the world and
rather than saying I have enough it's
enough he just said let's cap T bigger
bets let's swing even harder next time
it was never enough and he eventually
the last time he went broke he
eventually ended up killing himself it's
the most amazing like just fascinating
life that you can imagine of someone who
is so good at making money but never
knew when to stop and it is actually the
more money he made the more risk he
wanted to take so it was always like his
I I think his outcome was always
predestined because there was never
going to be a moment like the Richer he
be the more successful he became the
higher the odds that he was going to
fail and I think there's some version of
that for a lot of people because it
because their success increases their
confidence more than their ability and
they don't even know that that's a
problem that you can't self diagnose
like if you're confident you think it's
earned and you think it's real and and
then because you're successful a lot of
people who when you were poor or less
successful they would tell you you're
being an idiot you're wrong you're not
right about this but when you're rich
they maybe because you employ them or
because they think that you're so smart
even when you say something stupid they
might go yeah maybe it's right go for it
and therefore you don't have people who
are telling you how overconfident you
are that again it comes down to humility
doesn't it a lot of it yeah and like I
think that's that's that's so much of it
like and I think you have to go out of
your way sometimes for that humility
that when you have some level of success
in your life whatever that level is just
always remind yourself I think I
remember there was a quote that I think
it was um Roman Warriors that when they
would come home from a battle that they
won and they were in like the Parade of
you know like we won the battle and
we're going to go in the parade that
like we're we're the victors were so
great that they would have someone by
their side whispering in their ear
something something along on the lines
of you're not that great because they're
in this parade where they're glorious
and like Victorious but they need to
someone to bring them back down to earth
and be like hey you're just a you're
just a dude you're just a guy you're not
that special you're very fallible like
make the like tame it down they would
actually hire people to do that for them
and I think if you look at a lot of like
the great entrepreneurs a lot of the
great investors they will have some sort
of partner with that Charlie Munger is
that to Warren Buffett like when Warren
Buffett comes up with idea a big part of
Charlie munger's job is to tell him when
he's being an idiot and to have someone
like Warren Buffett who will trust a
person like that and to have someone
like Munger who is willing to do
something like that is so critical just
a quick Interruption for a brand that is
very close to us here at the dire of a
CEO who are sponsoring this episode of
this podcast and that is British Airways
if you're like me and you love a good
deal I think you're going to want to
hear about this the British Airways
business class sale is in full swing and
the potential savings are enormous we're
talking Savings of up to £1,000 on a
return business class flight to places
like New York Boston and Chicago plus
you can save even more on their
incredible packages to both the USA and
to Europe that includes those premium
business class flights and a luxury
hotel stay there's something different
about flying business with British
Airways as I think you guys will know if
you've ever done it it's not just the
seat that converts fully into a flat bed
or the menu or the fact that you can
watch the dire of a CEO on the inflat
entertainment system it's the Personal
Touch the experts that make you feel
relaxed and at home in the sky and
here's the thing you've got until the
13th of November so don't sit on it head
over to ba.com to find your deal now
quick one I discovered a product which
has changed my life called Eight sleep
this product eight sleep which are a
sponsor of this podcast has been a
revelation in my life because the eight
sleep pod cover which is basically a
fitted sheet that goes over your
mattress controls the temperature of
your bed throughout the night and it
follows Nature's natural Rhythm it's
starts cool gets colder while you go
into different phases of sleep and then
heats up slightly as you wake up in the
morning which is effectively guiding you
to have a deeper more restorative sleep
I genuinely think of all the things that
we would include in health and fitness I
think sleep now is the the most
important factor the thing that I'm
thinking about most often every single
day when I wake up in the morning the
first thing I do is I check my sleep and
I use that information to determine how
to proceed in that day how hard to work
out how many meetings to have what I
need to cancel what time I need to get
to bed so to celebrate them being a new
podcast sponsor I always want to get a
discount for you guys and I've got one
go to 8sleep.com which is EIG ghts
sleep.com
slst and if you do that you'll save
$150 on the Pod cover that I have on my
bed the one I'm talking about grab your
pod cover send me a DM and let me know
how you get on confidence which comes
from success often really does create
blind spots and that's something I think
about so much like how do I stay aware
of those blind spots in my life that you
know the success I've had in various
areas has undeniably created and
honestly a lot of I just go just save
loads of money Steve because the day
you're wrong you don't want to go broke
I often think about that like whenever
the curtain comes down on my career I
want to make sure that I can say like
hey thank you for for for letting me
have this I'm so grateful for it but I
I've saved enough that like I'm to pass
a baton to someone else and that's a
form of humility too there's a quote
from Denzel Washington where he's
talking to Will Smith After Will Smith
slapped Chris Rock remember that whole
debacle after that show Denzel
Washington comes up to Will Smith and he
says will when you're at your highest
moment in your career that's when the
devil's going to get you and it's like
when when when you when your career is
so high and you're so famous you think
so highly of yourself that you can do
anything that's when you're going to get
yourself into
trouble what a powerful quote and and I
think just paying attention to that
that's the natural humility that goes
into it and it's not false humility it's
not like oh I you know false humility is
like I I didn't do any of this I just
got lucky that's all false humility I
think real humility is like I built this
through hard work and I made some good
decisions but I'm just I'm just a guy
I'm as fallible as anybody else I think
that's it's that's not just important I
think that's critical to any amount of
sustainable success you taught me that
the price you pay to be wealthy is the
volatility you have to incur along the
way it's kind of how I think about it in
my head that's the cost of admission to
being to being wealthy and to to be to
any level of success is putting up with
an enduring unknowns and volatility and
Booms and busts and the other [__]
that you put up with in the investing
market and in your career and in your
relationships there's always a cost for
anything good in life there's a cost
that you have to pay like of course like
nothing's free like that but most of the
costs that you pay are not they don't
have a price tag that you can just
measure very cleanly like the cost of
doing well in investing is putting up
with volatility the cost of a successful
career might be long hours where you
were pulled away from your family the
cost of a relationship is like always
needing to sacrifice and compromise for
the other person nothing is ever free
and so much of the success in life is
just identifying what the cost is and
being willing to pay it because for all
of those things I just laid out
investing career relationships the cost
of admission is worth it putting up with
the volatility is worth it over time
because if you can put up with the stock
market falling 30% if you can just say
ah it's not that big a deal I'm just
going to hold tight 10 years from now
the cost is well worth doing that if you
can put up with the compromise that
takes to have a successful relationship
by and large that's going to be a cost
that's worth paying because you know
like so much of what matters in life is
just the relationships that you have and
once you identify the cost of that
relationship you're like oh I'll pay
that cost all day long so worth it this
requires you to be cognizant of time
Horizons and your own time Horizons
which is something you talk a lot about
in chapter 16 of the psychology of money
why is it important for us to know our
time Horizons and what you mean by time
Horizon it's the the amount of time
between now and whatever your goal is
which is very different for everybody
not just by your age but like if you
want to retire early or whatever it
would be like everyone's going to have a
slightly different time Horizon what's
yours mine I mean I you would break it
up into different chunks like I want to
get to a point or maybe I'm nearing a
point in my career where I'm just doing
things because I enjoy them there's
really no Financial incentive to what
I'm doing that's one time Horizon
another is like okay once my kids start
getting older I I want to make sure that
like I'm always there for them when they
need me teenage years are so difficult
for people like I'm always 247 I'll be
there for you which means I'm going to
have to pull back there's going to be a
point where I just say look I've
accomplished what I want to with writing
and I want to be able to move on to
something else and there's going to be a
point where I say I really don't want to
work that much anymore I just want to
move on and maybe I need to take care of
my parents would it be so like there's
multiple different time Horizons at
different goals of your life is buying a
house a good or bad financial decision
I'll tell you my own experience which
was in my 20s and early 30s my wife and
I lived in like seven different cities
and there was nothing better for us some
of those were just like let's try this
new city for fun some of it was moving
for work we moved for her school and our
ability to just get up and go hand the
keys back to the landlord nothing was
more valuable than that once we had our
son our first k did then very quickly
nothing became more valuable to me than
having an established secure home base
that nobody could take away from me that
was The Cure and also like kids are loud
and they scream and I didn't want
Neighbors in an apartment building that
I was going to have to like try to keep
my kid quiet for himself I I want my own
house that's mine and it's just a
standalone house my kid can scream as
loud as he wants not bothering anybody
else that became important to me like
instantly so it's I think people get
caught up when they're like well the
housing market returns 4 and a half% per
year that's it's like stop with the
spreadsheets like just do what's going
to work for you I know I know RIT sety
has a lot of thoughts about this on
renting versus buying and I think one
one of like the differences between REM
and myself is I have two young kids and
so like that that if I didn't have kids
I think I would be like rent rent
forever really and try and try different
cities move all move all around what can
be better than that but when you have
kids what's more important to me is
stability I want my kids to go to a
stable School know their neighbors have
friends that they can be friends with
for years that's important if we just
think about investing then in terms of
is buying a house a good Financial
investment my brother who works in my
company and he's the one that introduced
me to your book many many years ago said
to me something along the lines of Steve
don't buy houses to make money because
you have the ability to play a different
set of games that very few people can
play yeah and what I mean by that is he
kind of explained it to me goes listen
everyone can buy a house so the returns
there aren't going to be huge go find a
game that like only you can play you'll
get bigger returns if you're buying a
house because you think it's going to be
a good Financial investment stop like
even if it turns out in hindsight that
it was it doesn't matter I think these
are just purely lifestyle decisions and
I think so many people get screwed up
when they're in a spot in their life
where they should be renting because
they need to be mobile they need to move
around to a new job new career new
school whatever it is but they end up
buying because they think they're going
to make money doing it and that's like
that's the problem so I own a house and
if I ended up losing money on it I I I I
don't think I'd care that that's not why
I'm owning it I'm owning it just because
I want the stability for my family I've
just made an offer on my first ever
house and I because I played I played
other money games for the last decade of
My Life um and now I have a partner and
we've been together many years and we're
both like 31 years old and we're getting
into that position now you know yep and
my brother explained to me he goes
listen this is a bad financial decision
but it's a good emotional social life
decision
and you need to know how to separate the
two don't mark this down as a way that
you're trying to make money like you
might make money in 20 years time if you
just like if you're still living there
look at it as you know you need
somewhere to live and he must have got
that from you when I when I when we
bought our last house which was after I
wrote this book so this is a different
experience um I thought at the time and
still think today I I probably paid a
little bit too much I mean I paid the
market rate but if you said like oh did
you get a good deal I said no no not
didn't bother me in the slightest that's
not what I was doing it for it would I
mean it would be like if you asked like
if someone is deciding whether or not to
have kids and they think about the cost
of kids like forget of course you're
going to dump hundreds of thousands or
millions of dollars into your kids and
it's going it's like if if money is
coming into the equation like stop right
there this is it should not do it you're
doing it for very different reasons this
is not an investment people people buy
houses because they think that they're
making loads of money from because there
have been periods in time in which
people have made loads of money
historically like that's the anomaly
historically in the US and the UK how
housing prices adjust for inflation go
nowhere it's just been the last 20 or 30
years that there's this very brief
window of time that owning a house was a
great investment Robert Schiller won the
Nobel Prize about a decade ago for his
work in showing that over the last 150
years in the United States adjusted for
inflation most home prices have been
flat as a pancake it's just the last 20
years that have inflated people's
expectations of what a house can
do statistically there's going to be at
least one person listening to this that
has made an offer as we speak for a
house under the assumption that it's
going to help them stack
wealth if they were purely doing it for
those reasons what would you tell them
to do instead if that's purely the
reason run for run for your life don't
do it particularly I mean it it used to
be and maybe it still is like this in
many cities in America in the UK but it
used to be that rentals were almost
without exception shitty houses there
were no good rentals a big change change
at least in America in the last 20 years
is that most big cities have tons and
tons of luxury apartments to live in and
that are great places to live and
they're in the city centers and they got
beautiful granite countertops and
they're great places to live don't fall
for the idea that you can't live well if
you're renting I think that's that's
that's the problem and realize that if
you're doing it for financial reasons
you're probably about to borrow a
shitload of money for an investment that
historically has been a very bad
investment like if you put it in those
terms terms like what are we doing here
man you're going to borrow hundreds of
thousands of dollars for an investment
that historically has been a loss that's
what you're doing here does you feel
good about that that's what I'd say to
that person
godspeed I I would love to be in the
room somewhere where that person has
just looked at their partner after
persuading them to make that offer
because it was going to make them Rich
sorry guys the um this new
book same as ever essentially it's 23
short stories about things that never
change in the world y well there's a
couple of really interesting things that
I pulled out one of them again which
really hit me in the face was this idea
that the best story wins I know this I
know this intuitively I talk about it on
stage but I don't think people
understand the power of the best story
wins because when you think about
entrepreneurship or investing or
pitching or sales what most people do is
they lead out with facts stats and
figures yeah and even one of the things
I've noticed about you from our
conversation now is you have a
remarkable ability to tell stories thank
you and there's a huge power in that
prove to me that the best story wins I
mean it's it's always the case that it's
not the right answer or the best answer
or the mathematically accurate answer
it's just whoever gets people to nod
their heads in the right direction
that's who's going to win over time some
of the examples of this that I Love Ken
Burns one of the most famous uh
documentary filmmakers of all time most
of what is are in his
documentaries is is information that
people already know he'll make a
documentary about the Civil War World
War II Vietnam whatever it would be
there's not you're not learn necessarily
learning something new in there but he
is massively successful massively
popular because he's probably the
greatest Storyteller of our time so even
when you're taking information that
people already know if you can spin a
good story about it you get people
lining up and they will knock your door
down to listen to you one other example
of this are people who tell comedy if
you're a good comedian
like that's all just storytelling and a
lot of what a good comedian does is Tak
something that's very obvious and simple
but you can make you can tell a good
story about it you can make people laugh
and all a sudden you get their attention
and they'll remember it you said in the
book not the best idea or the right idea
or the most rational idea just whoever
tells a story that catches people's
attention I think there are dangerous
stories which is when people want to is
when people tell you what you want to
hear oh I got a dangerous story The
vaccine gives you autism I think I think
it's a story that people wanted to hear
some people wanted to hear that and if
you tell people what they want to hear
you can be wrong forever and people
won't care cuz you tell them what they
want to hear T shot who's a
neuroscientist sat here and she told me
a story of Donald Trump stood on the
debate stage and they panned over to Dr
Tucker Carson I believe he's called and
asked him about the vaccine and he
basically gave stats facts and figures
He said That vaccine doesn't give kids
autism and then they like pan over to
Donald Trump and Donald Trump tells this
elaborate story about a friend of his
one person one friend of his clearly
doesn't exist one friend of his and he
describes the needle like this he goes
this huge needle yeah and he so vivid
Vivid personal and emotional yep and you
get people nodding their heads to that
and and and capturing their attention
tally said I'm a neuroscientist I knew
it was wrong however there was something
about hearing it that even as a
neuroscientist I looked at my daughter
and go [__] I think we've always been
storytellers and that's what's really
set humans apart that's the whole idea
from youal Noah Harari is that like what
sets humans apart is our ability to tell
and remember stories and it's made it so
it's just a tool to simplify facts in
the world like most people the other
thing is powerful about stories is that
you remember them and you think about in
school when you had a math test and the
teacher just said memorize this formula
to regurgitate it on the test literally
5 minutes after the test is done you
forget it you have no idea what it was
but if you remembered a good story even
that you were told when you were 2 years
old you remember it for the rest of your
life so it's just a tool for getting
people to remember how the world works
and they can be so persuasive and so
good at eliminating the uncertainty that
greats on all of us that people will
listen to and believe things even when
they're just obviously flagrantly not
true if it's what they want to hear
people talk about um when we're talking
about investing but generally life
people talk about compounding interest
and we all know the I think a lot of
people should know the power of
compounding interest now but we rarely
think about how compounding interest can
negatively slowly impact our lives and
in your chapter about tiny and
magnificent you explore that and again
this hit me like a Chuck in the face
because I I think I spend my time now
thinking about how getting things to
compound in my fa favor will change my
life but I don't spend a huge amount of
time thinking about how things are
compounding against me right now yeah
what what's really true is that most
good news happens slowly and most bad
news happens very fast so bad news is
like Co literally happens overnight boom
you got a you got a virus it's going to
kill millions of people shut down the
economy happens literally overnight 911
happens start to finish it's like 30
minutes like boom just happens
immediately good news is usually slow
compounding over time so I use the
example of the book of like the
Improvement in heart disease mortality
over the last 70 years is Bonkers we've
made so much progress and saved
literally tens of millions of lives in
the fact that we've gotten better at
treating heart disease and but nobody
talks about it it's like most people are
aren't even aware that it's happened
because if you look at what happened
it was the mortality improved it got
better by about 2% per year now if you
compound 2% per year for 70 years it's
off the charts like we're like living in
such a better world now than we were 70
years ago but in any given year you
didn't even notice it you're never going
to see a news headline like breaking
news heart disease mortality improves by
1.4% that's not a headline like all the
headlines are bad news because bad news
happens fast so once you realize that
then it's like most of the news is going
to skew negative not because there's
some producer who's trying to toy with
your brain it's just because what is
obviously happening today tends to be
the bad news where the good news is just
very slowly compounding over
time that can go in the other direction
of like bad news that compounds over
time I think about our health smoking
Health like that's to like and like one
cigarette is not going to do anything
bad for you but one cigarette per day
for 30 years is catastrophic and so
that's that's really what it was like
same with like getting one bad night's
sleep not that big a deal but if if
you're sleeping 6 hours a night every
night for years on end you're going to
reduce your life expectancy by a
tremendous amount this idea of
compounding interest and compounding
returns and how important it is I've
spent so long trying to explain to
people that compounding interest and
compounding returns this very hard thing
to think about is so important I imagine
you have two what is your go-to way of
explaining to like your eight-year-old
kid or someone else the power of
compounding we were actually going to
get like a bowl of rice here and I was
going to do some experiments the rice is
the best the the rice sport experiment
if you if people aren't familiar with it
it's this story that's probably not true
that back 500 years ago someone uh you
know told the king they said hey here's
a here's a chess board I'm going to put
one grain of rice on the
first Square two on the second Square
four on the third and then let's do that
and by the end of the chess board that's
like it's like more rice than exists in
the entire world because like if you
double something again and again and
again it's just completely
counterintuitive how big it can grow the
one way that I I I had a friend of mine
Michael batnick explained this to me
years ago or I think he wrote this in a
blog post he said if I ask you what is 8
plus 8 plus 8 plus 8 you can do that in
your head like it's it's not it's not
that hard but if I say what is 8 time 8
time 8 time 8 like forget about it even
if you are really mathematically
inclined there's no way you can like
very few people could figure that out in
their head so our minds are just not
good at exponential thinking that's just
not it's it's just not something that
we're really geared towards doing like 8
plus 8 plus it's like so simple linear
thinking so simple exponential thinking
not intuitive in the slightest and
because it's not intuitive it's so
common to underestimate what smoking is
going to do to you that compounds over
time what investing is capable of doing
to your wealth because it's so
counterintuitive that 99% of Warren
Buffett's net worth came after he was 60
years old not intuitive at all and so
since exponential thinking is not
intuitive both on the positive and the
negative side we go through life
underestimating what's going to happen
to us in good things and bad things it's
like a religion we have to adopt I think
I think that's a great way it's it's
like a mathematical religion because
just like a lot of religion it's like
it's not intuitive and it almost takes
like a leap of faith to be like I know
it seems crazy but this is this is what
I believe I think there's a sense of
that to compounding where like it's just
math you can just put the numbers in a
spreadsheet and they'll tell you what it
is but since it's not intuitive there's
almost like a religious aspect that you
need to believe how powerful it can be
over time two of the chapters in your
book same as ever speak to the
importance of discomfort one of the
chapters is called when the magic
happens and you say in that chapter
stress pain discomfort shock and disgust
for all its tragic
downsides it's also when the magic
happens and then the other chapter where
you kind of speak to this is It's
supposed to be hard most things worth
pursuing charge their fee in the form of
stress uncertainty dealing with quirky
people bureaucracy other people's
conflicting incentives hassle nonsense
long hours and constant doubt that's the
overhead cost of getting ahead what's
interesting is I never tied those two
chapters together but you're right
there're they're almost the exact same
idea that for the the whole economy for
the whole world when the biggest
improvements in society takes place is
when there's some sort of disaster like
for all of its obvious downside and
death and destruction nothing has been
more technologically Progressive for the
world than World War I the number of
inventions that came out of World War II
from atomic energy to Jets and like go
on down the list penicillin all of these
lists for things that you and I are
taking advantage of today happen not in
spite of but because of World War II
because there was this period where
everyone in the world came together and
they're like holy [__] we got a big
problem to figure out let's put our
heads together and figure this out right
now but that's also on a personal level
on a personal level it happens as well
too like there there's there's there's a
book written many years ago called the
upside of down that's I thought that was
just a brilliant title like the like the
upside of being down and it happens a
lot that when you have maybe it's a job
layoff or a breakup or a medical
emergency whatever it can be that it
changes you for the good and it's hard
it's always impossible to see that
silver lining in the moment you don't
ever imagine there's going to be a
silver lining in that moment but when
you look back in hindsight it will be I
saw this recent example of this that
really knocked me on my ass it was
Steven coar who I might be getting these
details wrong but I think when he was uh
a young child his father and brother
died tragically and he said at one point
that uh I don't want to put words in his
mouth but he said something along the
lines of like he is grateful for that
and he was asked like what do you mean
you're grateful for that and he said
look of course I wish it never happened
but it allowed him to understand the
emotions of other people and get closer
to other people who had also experienced
something like that and so even in like
the deepest darkest moment of his life
that he says he of course he wishes it
didn't happen it taught him something
about Humanity that he's grateful for
today that's an extreme example but I
think for a lot of people being laid off
from a job in the moment is going to be
the hardest thing they've ever dealt
with and in hindsight it's going to be
one of the best things that ever
happened to their career
a breakup might be the hardest thing
you've ever been through and in
hindsight it might be the best thing
that's ever happened to you so I that's
always like that's when the magic
happens is when things get really tough
It's just always impossible to see that
when you're going through it a lot of
people would have clicked on to this
conversation and if they've gotten to
the end of the conversation well done to
them what conclusion can we offer them
based on everything we've talked about
as it specifically relates to wealth
creation and money first I think for
both of these books we're almost ending
exactly where we started which is like I
hope they get you to think about your
life in a different way both of these
books and the Publishers hated this
there's no advice in the books never do
I say and therefore you should do this
and the publisher wants you to do that
and I said no no no because I don't know
you I don't know the person reading this
book who am I to say what you should do
with your own life I don't even know
what to do with my own life but I hope
it gets you thinking about what you want
and who you are and what you are capable
of what you're not capable of if it gets
you thinking about your life then I
think I've been successful doing this
rather than trying to assume that I
could give you specific advice about
what to do Morgan we have a closing
tradition on this podcast where the last
guest leaves a question for the next
guest not knowing who they're going to
be leaving it for and the question
that's been left for you
is what is your biggest regret in life
and how has that experience changed
you I think I've uh always been prone to
mild depression not not significant but
mild depression and anxiety and I wish I
could go back to different periods of my
life in a time machine and just say it's
G to be okay it's not going to be easy
it's not going to be perfect but it's
gonna it's it's going to be fine and I I
I look back not with regret but how much
time have I wasted worrying about things
that never happened and were're almost
certainly never going to happen a
tremendous amount and even if I
recognize that today I know I'm going to
worry about something tonight and
tomorrow and next week about something I
really shouldn't be worrying about I
don't know if I regret it because I
think having a sense of worry has kept
me safe A lot of times it's kept me out
of trouble in in a lot of things but I
do look back at the course of my life
and think man like I could have been
happier than I was if I had accepted a
certain level of just telling myself
it's going to be
okay well you're not going to have to
worry about your book because it's
superb thank you genuinely I I you know
hope my audience trust me um but I I
would really implore them to get both
books I mean the psychology of money I
think is the best book on money ever
written it's pretty much also the only
book I've ever read on money and then
same as ever is
just it's everything it's advice on
money life relationships everything that
matters because there are a set of
enduring principles that speak to the
fundamentals of life in a way that is
completely enduring you have a wonderful
ability to write enduring things and you
tell wonderful stories like you say I
actually didn't even notice that you
didn't give me advice when you said that
You' not given me advice in anything and
I never will to anybody bullshitting but
you know now you think about it you
didn't I I garnered my advice from the
stories you told and the evidence you
provided Morgan thank you so much I'm so
glad we've managed to have this
conversation and it's been a huge honor
and pleasure um to meet you thank you as
well because I can't imagine how many
millions of pounds you saved me by
writing this book genuinely it's such an
honor to do this with you stepen this
been a lot of fun thank
you as you'll know this podcast is
sponsored by H and we're going into that
last quarter of the year it's getting a
little bit colder back into our routines
back into our work rhythms and it's in
those moments that I need to focus most
on my diet as I get back into the swing
of work I need to get back into a
routine as it relates to my diet and
that's really where hu's RTD their ready
to drink range comes in handy in a
bottle you have a nutritionally complete
meal that you can consume in a minute so
this is a real Lifesaver in terms of my
health it is my Ally and my friend and
my companion on my busiest days and it
means that even when I'm pursuing all of
my professional goals my health goals
can be pursued at the same time there's
a link in the description below if
you've never tried Hills rtds this is
the time if you're falling off of the
wagon this is the sign you needed to get
back on there's a link below in the
description order yourself a pack stay
healthy throughout this busy period do
you need a podcast to listen to next
we've discovered that people who liked
this episode also tend to absolutely
love another recent episode we've done
so I've linked that episode in the
description below I know you'll enjoy
it
[Music]
ah